on démarre avec l'actualité en Ukraine
le chef de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique est arrivée à la
centrale nucléaire de zaporigia Rafael
grossit va évaluer la situation après la
destruction du fameux barrage de
carloska la centrale nucléaire est
occupée par les forces russes on va
écouter Raphaël grossiste
je dirais qu'il y a deux éléments
fondamentaux d'une part nous constatons
que la situation est grave et que les
conséquences sont là et qu'elles sont
réelles
des mesures sont prises
pour stabiliser la situation
et on trouve tout de suite Gulliver
Craig à Kiev gilet vous tous vous
rentrez tout juste en fait deux aporidja
cette visite de Raphaël grossi a déjà
été reporté a été reportée à aujourd'hui
pour des raisons de sécurité quelle
évaluation a-t-il fait de la situation
oui je pense que j'ai vu le cortège de
Raphaël grossi en fait qui venait dans
le sens inverse alors que je me
dirigeais vers Kevin devait effectuer
cette visite hier pour des raisons de
sécurité parce que c'est une ligne de
front active qui sépare la ville des
aporisa tenue par les Ukrainiens de la
centrale des épaules qui est occupé par
les forces russes mais Raphaël grossit
aujourd'hui on l'a entendu dans le
sonore il a dit que même si la situation
est inquiet est inquiétante il est
satisfait des mesures qui sont prises en
réalité la situation liée à la baisse du
niveau d'eau dans réservoir de carroufka
n'est pas très urgent de la vie de tous
les experts puisque tous les réacteurs
de la centrale sont éteint donc elle n'a
pas un besoin très urgent de grande
quantité d'eau pour se refroidir et
Raphaël grossit a dit que les mesures
pour remplir les réservoirs privés qui
servent la centrale des aporisa d'autres
sources sont en train d'être pris
l'autre inquiétude qu'il y a c'est lié
plus au combat et la possibilité que des
frappes tombent sur le territoire de la
centrale bien sûr pour pénétrer les murs
épais des réacteurs et des blocs
énergétiques il faudrait vraiment impact
extrêmement important ils sont quand
même construits pour résister des
impacts il y a d'autres sites sur le
territoire de la centrale qui peuvent
être une source d'inquiétude notamment
des sites où sont stockés des déchets
radioactifs ce ne serait pas un deuxième
Tchernobyl si quelque chose comme ça
venait d'être frappé par une requête
mais il y aurait quand même du matériel
radioactif qui serait dégagé ce serait
un accident assez grave avec des
conséquences sur la région donc ça c'est
l'une des inquiétudes généralement vous
savez Raphaël grossit avec ses visites
n'a pas une très très bonne réputation
en Ukraine même si vous le dit quand il
a rencontré keV avant-hier la